our biology really tells us that at our
hearts we are libertarians okay here
everybody thanks for having me I'm
having a ball this great weekend or what
come on
and we engineered the weather to be
perfect okay so we'll have you do some
experiments with me today okay so if you
would take your right foot and just do a
clockwise circle clockwise circle
clockwise circle and go in the air and
draw a big number six big number six Oh
what happened
John what happened you wait yeah wait
you went the wrong direction aren't you
in charge of you now I'm confused okay
so why did you do that
your foot went the wrong direction right
once you drew that six Oh Robert knows
the reason why this happens and I'll
tell you the reason later I'm not going
to tell you now it's a good neurologic
reason why this happens what does that
tell us who's in charge of you right as
some level we are volitional beings we
can choose the way we go through life
another level we can't choose as were
driven by underlying unconscious
processes and if we will understand at a
fundamental level how individuals make
decisions then we need to interrogate
the brain and find those underlying
unconscious processes so I started doing
this about 10 years ago
investigating the way people make
decisions in the laboratory a feel
founded by our friend Vernon Smith to
understand why people made certain
decisions that seemed not to have made
sense okay so let me give you another
example of that so this is experiment
you can do next weekend when you're at a
cocktail party and you meet someone new
and how are you what are you doing you
can say I just learned that markets are
moral okay so the person you tell us to
will have one of two reactions in my
experience will be anger what's wrong
with you are you insane person have you
not seen CNN the second will be these
sort of sad views that we give to
individuals who are mentally challenged
okay it's okay
understand so I want to try to convince
you at the level of the brain that
markets are moral okay so I joked with
Amy that I would call this talk wide
everything you think is true actually is
true so so I just made a really bold
statement and you need to say now prove
it how do I know that right well I have
philosophy I have sociology have this
and that but could I get to their like
the level of how the brain works but
actual brain chemistry so I started
looking at this issue ten years ago I
thought why is it that we live in a
world in which we can engage in all
kinds of transactions
so generally wealth improving
transactions good for you good for me in
which there's a low level of cheating in
the United States like very low level of
cheating so when we looked at how people
ran these experiments I should say that
when I lived in Arizona I randomly would
come by and knock on Verna's door and he
nicely never told me to get away and I
said what happens in your experiments
why do people do what they do and for
this particular experiment where to tell
you about a minute what we have subjects
who can invest with a stranger in the
lab their money can grow but then this
stranger has a decision to make which is
do I share the gains from this
transaction with the other person who
invest with me or do I keep it all if
you do this one time and you're
anonymous the standard models and
economics said money good you should
keep the money and yet almost no one did
that so I asked Vernon why is it what do
people tell you in these experiments and
you know what the most common answer is
I don't know students could report will
how they were doing what they're doing
ok so now we're in this corner we're
stuck how can we understand why people
reciprocate in transactions even when
they don't have to
so for crazy reasons that have to do
with my weird background which you can
hear about later I decided I'll try to
run this experiment that Vern invented
and after people made their decision
take four tubes of blood from their arm
okay this is the birth of what my former
dean called vampire economics okay so I
am a vampire
I'm outed now of a blood freezer full of
blood in my office we found is that a
particular chemical that at that time in
humans was only known to contract the
uterus during birth and the release when
women breastfed and was released while
both sexes had sex but that was it a
reproductive hormone in fact was
released was someone invested their
money with you and this hormone is
called
oxytocin which many of you now have
heard about but in 2001 one of my
colleagues said why would you study that
that's the world's stupidest idea it's
just a female hormone so this for women
of course can be very important this was
a man but men make this too and in
particularly group living animals like
us we have this hormone released by men
and women not only for reproductive
stimuli but in fact when we have
positive social interactions that's what
we showed and so one of the fundamental
issues I think that gets back to why
Marcus our moral is that we have a
biology for reciprocation that's the
basis for trade so when we are trusted
when someone wants to do a business deal
with us we want to reciprocate that deal
because that's what we normally do ok
this leaves opens a couple of questions
number one what happens when the deal
goes bad and what about Bernie Madoff
okay so let's take those two on okay so
we also asked about that what if someone
doesn't play nice what happens in the
brain we found is that we also have not
only a biology of reciprocation but we
have a biology for punishment why is
this interesting so the less you play
nice with me the more particularly for
men the more I want to punish you we see
this associated with a spike in
testosterone so the male responds to you
not playing nice is I want to take you
outside and beat on you okay so I will
punish you why is that important because
if I know through my experience in life
if I don't play nice I'll get an
aggressive response I'll play nicer so
just the threat of punishment me
that I now have to adjust my behavior
given the environment I'm in so I don't
need Big Brother watching me right I
don't need a camera prepper transaction
I don't need to you know have my DNA
taken every time I slice my credit card
what I need you to know is that the
expectation is that you're going to
reciprocate and if you don't people
don't like it I'm gonna try to do
something about it so we may have formal
solution elections allow us to do this
without beating people up but the
impulse is the same we want to
reciprocate we are hyper social
creatures trade is deep in our DNA so
oxytocin first appeared a variant of it
in fish 400 million years ago so it's
not like trade is something new that
humans impose on us in fact the party
line is that somehow you know exchange
in the markets degrades human dignity it
puts a price and everything is somehow
exploitative right that's you know
sounds like Marxism but it goes back to
Aristotle and to Confucius and many
others not true at all you look at the
biology we are set up to interact with
each other and exchanging this for that
is one of those interactions again if I
give you the money you don't give me the
goods I'm gonna go after you that's the
way we are okay and I'm certainly gonna
tell all my friends in ostracize you so
now we have what essentially as a
self-organizing trade system it's that
system of trade within a stable
environment that has produced enormous
increases in wealth Marcus are as you
know the best and fastest way to
increase prosperity humans have ever
found and markets are the most natural
thing for us to trade in we are set up
for it it makes perfect sense to us it's
consistent with our human nature so that
should make you feel good we are set up
to do this it's not an imposition from
above it's just what we do naturally and
so if you've gone to primitive areas
which many of you have you see markets
evolve right away in fact interesting
anthropological evidence shows that when
you see underdeveloped and small-scale
societies as they start to trade they
actually become
more fair so when anthropologists do
experiments just like Vernon did and I
did in a lab in which you can exchange
goods and have an unfair or fair outcome
the more you trade the more in fact
people in the laboratory or field
laboratory want to share the benefits so
trade really is about sharing benefits
why because life is long
we have histories people find out about
us and if they say John's not a fear
dealer everyone avoids him right he is
no longer part of the social group
that's not adaptive her social creature
okay so our biology really tells us that
at our hearts we are libertarians go
figure okay so you can try the
experiment I suggest at the next
cocktail party and see what people do
but that's the story you can tell them
we're built for this okay what about the
Bernie Madoff is there cheating for sure
and if you leave a cash stack on the
table people will try to grab that sack
of cash for sure we found in our
experiments with thousands of thousands
of people not only college students but
real free-roaming humans then in fact 5%
of them don't release oxytocin on
stimulus these 5% have very unusual
psychological profiles they look a lot
like Psychopaths so they are self
deceptive they're deceptive they are
manipulative they don't attach to one
person at a time so they really don't
form relationships well and they're kind
of in survival mode so what produces
this one is you get a bad genetic drop
it just doesn't work this system the
second is that you have a bad childhood
so find neglect or abuse you enough in
animals and humans the system doesn't
develop I don't get this feedback system
and the third is I'm having a really bad
day the dog died I got in a car accident
I'm very stressed so high levels of
stress put us in survival mode they may
be normally nice people but I'm really
grumpy today and I'm gonna behave that
so it turns out in these 10 years of
worth of experiments that this same
mechanism oxytocin release motivates
virtuous behaviors of every sort and
these are not hypothetical
virtuous behaviors these are stack of
money share it keep it do what you want
and when we induce oxytocin release or
when we manipulate it from collage eclis
we raise oxytocin levels in the brain
people are more generous more
compassionate more trustworthy honest
sacrificial so this is really the
substance that differentiates us from
almost every other animal we like being
around the other humans and one of the
things we like being around the other
humans is we can trade with them so Adam
Smith identified this in The Wealth of
Nations when the extent of the market is
broad the opportunities for wealth
creation are also broad ok so the
take-home message here is that markets
reflect our human nature and our human
nature is one of morality morality is
what keeps us embedded in the social
group if we're not moral if we don't
have the moral rules so what's
appropriate to do and not to do we
haven't internalized those
physiologically then we're stuck with
another system which is always being
monitored
people telling us what to do and
stealing the money whenever we can if
we're reciprocal creatures then we can
live in a decentralized society we have
a large group of individuals that we can
interact with and when we have that
large group of individuals then the
wealth creation is optimized so that's
really what the biology is looking like
it looks like for most people most of
the time as long as you have choice we
have lots of opportunities to interact
and so that's the sense notion markets
are moral they depend on our moral
character without that we'd have Big
Brother in every transaction that we've
tried that model it's called the Soviet
Union right where I tell you who you
wreck with how much blah blah blah that
doesn't work because it rounds out our
innate reciprocity when we have freedom
of choice and say John great guy I'd
like to do a business deal with him now
if you take advantage of me if he screws
me over I have some recourse I'm going
to get aggressive when I try to get that
back and I'm never going to do that
business with him again right so as long
as we have enough freedom of choice
this system can kick in so I think
that's actually really new knowledge
that this sense that we all have that we
are reciprocal creatures that we are
doing things that are we
Winn solutions actually has a real
biological basis that's it
so try the experiment ask some questions
and see if you can give us people that
it's our innate morality that's
reflected in markets that allows all
kinds of competition to occur but in a
sense in which we're respecting other
people's autonomy independence and their
own sense of reason thank you for